bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors le ms fonde sa
décision sur les résultats des essais
solidarité discovery est ce que c'est
justifié selon vous en tout cas c'était
tout à fait prévisible puisque
effectivement à et grands essais
contrôlés fait par différents types de
pays en france en angleterre ou ailleurs
n'ont pas trouvé d'effet positif chez
des patients sévèrement atteints par le
cos vide et donc des patients
hospitalisés
seul sait n'a pas d'effet pour ni
positif ni négatif
bon ce n'est pas la première fois que l'
oms
stop ces essais cliniques concernant les
drogues si chloroquine il ya un
rétropédalage est ce que véritablement
l'organisation mondiale de la santé se
montre fiables sur la polémique autour
de ce traitement
l oms a réagi un peu rapidement après
l'article frauduleux du à deux ans est
en arrêtant tous les essais là
simplement à la halle a tenu compte du
fait que dans la plupart des autres
études elle le bras et drôle si klose
qui n'avait été arrêté faute de
résultats probants
donc cette fois ci ça me semble ça me
semble logique mais ça ne veut pas dire
que l'hydroxyde routine n'a pas un effet
préventif d'une aggravation de la
maladie mais pour ça il faut les données
beaucoup plus précocément et avant
d'arriver à l'hôpital type de travail
que fait didier raoult mais comme il n'a
pas voulu faire d'études contrôlées
on sait pas pourquoi effectivement il ya
des très bons résultats
son aspect du traitement préventif 1 les
études vont se poursuivre en tout cas
oui je crois que c'est une chance pour
suivre sur l'a10 il ya de moins en moins
de cas ça va être difficile pour une
raison très simple c'est que la très
grosse majorité des gens qui sont
atteints par ce virus finissent par
guérir sans avoir besoin d'aller à
l'hôpital donc il faut des très très
grand nombre pour montrer à un effet
donc je pense que ça va être difficile
de savoir un jour si oui ou non
didier raoult a raison selon vous quel
est aujourd'hui le traitement qui
suscite le plus d'espoirs actuellement
aujourd'hui dans la dans les phases
précoces et d'ailleurs moment vous
commencez à tous et avoir de la fièvre à
ne plus avoir de goût et l'odorat
il ya aucun traitement qui est pour
l'instant de montrer comme efficaces et
je vous dis d'être aussi coquine on n'en
sait rien
et donc il n'y a pas grand chose à faire
que de se surveiller et ne sera pas
d'aller à l'hôpital à l'hôpital ce qui a
été montré par l'étude a recovery à
quelles études à anglet c'est qu'à un
anti inflammatoire de synthèse bien
connu qui s'appelait d'exams l'état zone
pour être très efficace diminuerait la
mortalité chez ces patients qui sont
très sévèrement atteints par park ovide
10 nov
et donc ça doit intéressant de les
donner chez ceux qui ont un syndrome
inflammatoire une exacerbation de leurs
de leurs inflammations chez chez ces
patients là à l'examen et à zone
pourrait être utile alors même qu'ils
sûr que moi je me posais voir qu'elle
n'a pas de réponse c'est faudrait-il
donner de l'appeler xam états zone chez
certaines ces patients traités au bout
c'est à dire avant même qu'il soit à
l'hôpital
on a de quoi mesurer à la réaction
inflammatoire il ya des supers le
couramment ville dans les laboratoires
de biologie et on peut savoir quels sont
les patients qui ont à cette réaction
inflammatoire exacerbée c'est à dire
trop importante
dès le début de la maladie et peut-être
qu'il faudrait donner de la
dexaméthasone à ce moment là mais là
encore c'est compliqué va te faire un
étude bien fait parce que on est on est
pas le capital on est en ville et c'est
difficile de faire des essais contrôlés
dans ces conditions en tout cas l oms a
salué d'ailleurs l'essai clinique
britannique avec
l'espoir sur concernant le médicament
dexaméthasone son coût aussi à l'oeil
est le coût de ce médicament qui serait
bas tout comme c'est le cas pour la
chloroquine ans également
oui la laddh exams états homme ça coûte
quelques quelques dizaines d'euros à
peut-être même moins par par jour
donc effectivement ça c'est quelque
chose qui est qu'elle est tout à fait
possible à donner partout dans tout
l'est dans tous les pays
et ce qui est étonnant c'est que en fait
les airs est minable des animateurs
français ont dit mais là d'examen et à
zone on en donne déjà chez nous
massivement alors ça m'a un peu surpris
d'entendre d'entendre salle à la
télévision parce que ainsi celle
réellement le cas
il fallait faire une étude à l'étude
française discovery tête est plein de
choses mais parlait d' examiner tyson et
aucune étude à ma connaissance a été
fait en france à avant de prescrire
largement animations l'exam états zone
ce qui me fait un petit peu rires parce
qu'on a reproché à didier raoult à ne
pas faire d'études qu'elle contrôle
et puis les personnes qui lui rapproché
ça on fait exactement pareil avec la
dexaméthasone base donc c'est en fait à
faites ce que je dis ne faites pas ce
que je fais il faut s'attendre à un
destin similaire pour le dexaméthasone
avec les drogues sicot chloroquine pour
l'instant l'étude contrôlé à britannique
semble dire que c'est efficace
je pense que d'autres pour mon neurone
le dira un peu plus tard donc si on
considère que ces études contrôlées ses
dires 4control avec des gens qui ne sont
pas traités par dexaméthasone l'autre
qui en prime à montrer quelque chose
c'était ce qu'on appelle nous un niveau
de preuve qui est un intéressant
important il faut que ce soit confirmé
bien entendu mais ça ça devient quelque
chose d'intéressant mais attention c'est
chez des patients très très très
sévèrement atteints c'est pas c'est pas
chez tout le monde et moi je me pose la
question de
l'intérêt peut-être de le faire plus tôt
pour éviter justement cette aggravation
des symptômes car il va souvent en
particulier chez des gens les plus âgés
merci beaucoup à vous philippe oeuvre
gagnent je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur en médecine de précision du
métabolisme et de la génomique à
l'université lille 2